hello ladies I love the fashion oh in
the film in this moment
I did because my jumpsuit I was wearing
a jumpsuit before and it was sliding
down oh and so I was like you know what
it's it's nice it's like so clean and
it's really soft I feel like I'm wearing
a blanket no you guys are kind of
coordinated
is this Tom Brown it is Tom Brown you
look oh God I mean I'm wearing the same
thing I was wearing earlier I just got a
jacket off but this is so good I just
like how many pockets I have yeah oh
wait Jordan Pockets yeah what are this I
have secret pockets Tom Brown has given
me a little secret envelope so take that
to the airport
I don't have any spoilers are there
spoilers what
so who in the cast would you say would
make a really great detective in real
life
lastly oh because the chats yeah and
he's also he's really logical you know
he like I've never seen him like ever
I've never seen him lose any sort of
composure
to pass it in the cost Kate Hudson is
she but she well sorry I would agree no
I agree I think remember when she got
mad when we were playing games yes she's
the person yeah yeah she's the person
that yells at you if you're not playing
the game right okay so yes but also you
come a close second are you visited
close again I would never get mad songs
in a game of Clue who in the cast do you
think would do the best is it Kate still
okay but I think Leslie would figure it
out he just wouldn't do anything about
it yeah he'd be like hmm he's like oh
that I sold that okay and then he'd
leave like I'm gonna go hold my space
over here yeah no I agree probably Kate
Kate would get really invested yeah yeah
so murder mystery like this who would
you not want to know because they can't
keep a secret
you can't keep a secret hell no why oh I
don't know I like I I really I just
can't yeah I'm I'm you just feel you're
just too honest I'm uh she's an open
book mediocre acting terrible life what
I was kidding I'm just kidding and I'm
pretty sure that's a new girl
quote yeah really I think I might have
gotten it wrong though so Nick Miller
yeah
what a classic show it's great show yeah
sorry we're not okay sorry no I'm so
into it um who on the cast was the
funniest between takes
Catherine
I like how we're rinsing yeah yeah it's
true and lastly Knives Out Three who
would be someone you would dream of
having to watch on something like this
us me you yes
well it's been it's been fun ladies um
thank you thank you